first of all guys welcome back to
Toronto but Rivest is a big deal you're
gonna be screening zoetic there that
must feel pretty exciting yeah its first
time screening outside of the states so
that's pretty cool International yeah
that's that's exactly it and you guys
are international like you speak to the
entire world you've been doing it for
years I'm interested in knowing so you
hasn't been doing this for what like 15
16 years 10 years yeah this is what it's
like pre-youtube yeah it was a right
when YouTube was invented well I said
year before we were making you know me
Phillip and Ted were the founders we
weren't we were in class at UC San Diego
making videos for fun yeah and you know
we were hosting it on our own website
and then this thing called YouTube came
along we're like oh there's a there's a
website that's hosting videos and at
that time it was a novelty right you
know no one was doing online video free
bandwidth free bandwidth or like you
know we'll use that believes that not
knowing that a community could be
started yeah so it was really that the
very beginning so we're like the old
guys on YouTube for sure well like an
entrepreneurs dream at the time I'm sure
right and what's cool is like you know
in the early days of YouTube when people
are like oh there's a cool place to
watch cats play piano
you guys are we're going in hard on like
narrative we were yeah we always wanted
to do scripted narrative and we still do
I mean that's still kind of like our
bread and butter because we wanted to
show that you know Asian Americans could
be just normal characters not you know
the kung fu fighting yeah or you know
lawyers doctors engineers that we all
see in the mainstream media but we can
have normal love stories normal family
stories not friendship stories things
that we didn't really see in mainstream
YouTube was a great place for us to show
those well that isn't she because if you
I mean I grew up watching like HK dramas
yes he's like like like Chinese romantic
dramas Jay dramas and K dramas and all
that stuff and there was never any sort
of that representation even like to tell
a normal story about an Asian family was
impossible to see right it was an event
it was like wait they're not gonna
they're not gonna show them like throw a
kick or a punch at this point
there's a normal family story yeah yeah
it was very few and far between
yeah and now we've got you know the
farewell we've got zoetic do you think
that the output that you know you've
been doing over the last 50 years might
have actually had a hand in in that and
showing people getting to the mainstream
like yo these are the stories that we
can tell everybody like I hope so yeah I
think because because people can find
those normal stories on TV and movies
mainstream yeah YouTube was the place
and they look to us for those stories
and I think we hopefully we inspired
other people to tell those same stories
and realize that those stories do exist
yeah and it's also helped out like so
many of our friends that have come
through and been featured in our shorts
so people like Randall Park seem of
course Toronto native and you know Julie
as well she's been a longtime friend of
ours and having them come on and kind of
stretch their acting abilities and in
roles that they don't normally get you
know in the mainstream it's always
really cool to see that yeah it's more
about just bringing others that you know
I feel the same mission as us yeah I
really enjoy seeing someone like Randall
go and do like a big movie right do or
play Asian Jim and then you know you can
catch him on YouTube doing work with you
as well
Randall's so he's so awesome he's like
he's always down and from the very
beginning you know he was on fresh off
the boat yeah and he's been on there for
a long time but one year random random
Randall Lee randomly we said you know we
went to a Christmas short about an Asian
Santa Agent Santa Claus and he said I'm
down right away and this was like in the
middle of you know his busy season with
fresh off the boat and yeah he
definitely embraces what we're doing on
YouTube and is always a big proponent so
do you reach out to these people or do
they reach out to you like when you've
worked with Steve mail right how did
that work out so see me I believe he
reached out to us first I don't want her
to know that but I remember the first
time we were just in our office and then
the Phil came in with c'moon say oh this
is Seema he's on Kim's convenience he's
a big fan yeah
would love to do some stuff with us I
like oh cool nice nice to meet you and
yeah it was very organic in that sense
but we've we've reached out to people
too so it goes both ways I feel like in
the community everyone knows of each
other it's just waiting for that right
time to to really connect so that's one
Asian stereotype that seems to work we
gotta stick together yeah yeah
what something really interesting about
him and that you know the stage he's at
now where he's gonna be playing this
like big Marvel superhero character
which has never happened for yeah
someone in the Asian community before it
appears it's gonna be a lot of weight in
his shoulders a lot of expectations
what's your take on that I totally
understand and I I feel it for him yeah
at the same time like when I talk to him
personally I don't want every
conversation to be about that yeah I
want to remember when you know we would
just talk about Smash Brothers or you
know like we talked about things yeah
because literally we we shot a sketch
with him called best grand boyfriend
best Instagram boyfriend and then the
following week he got the news mm-hmm
and I just remember she was in our
office doing this one day shoot this
really silly kind of almost like
listicle thing about you know how to be
a good public service announcement yeah
right to be a good Instagram boyfriend
and next thing you know everyone's seen
that video
seeing shang-chi you know like I'm
thinking that's like that's the guy yeah
and I love that he he isn't like
forsaking that he's embracing everything
like yeah I do this stuff on YouTube but
I'm also gonna be the next
asian-american you know superheroes yeah
I love that he is very honest and it has
it hasn't really affected him in a way
that's changed his personality yeah yeah
given your your output like the amount
of videos that you put out and have made
over the years when it came to putting
together something like zoetic did it
feel like an easy transition like
something that you're always doing or
was there a shift in terms of like tone
or a jump in some certain way no I feel
I feel like those culturally authentic
stories are what we really are inspired
by our family stories and how our
upbringing really
acted us yeah so if anything he was just
working with Julie was working with
Julie as a writer and director was a
first because she's been in a lot of
short films of ours but working as a
behind the scenes as in that capacity
was new but those stories about family
and asian-american upbringing that the
that's very natural to us mhm mhm Benson
was our producer an ad on that so well
yeah so Julie was somebody actually met
very early on in my career I think both
of us barely just started so as soon as
the two of them asked me you know I do
want to produce I don't even know if
they finished the send themselves
already like when are we shooting what
are we doing what we need so it's really
cool it's just like you know cease see
somebody that's grown in the
asian-american acting world and have the
confidence to write and direct and star
in something that's so personal that was
just like really cool to see yeah it was
nice actually that a lot of it was in
Cantonese - we for zoetic we really
wanted to feel authentic and we were
gonna be unapologetic about how much of
it felt real to us yeah and you know
within the immigrant families most of
the time the parents they don't think
about their own happiness and as the
kids get older they see how much the
parents really sacrifice for them and
they want to make sure that our parents
are living a happy life regardless of
the kids like we're growing up we're
fine now that's a big message and we're
fine what about you you know and I you
don't get to say that enough and in the
Asian families we just don't ask each
other you know are you happy or are you
doing okay yeah so that was in a way a
love letter to our own families yeah I
an interesting point came up when I was
talking to to Lilly Singh on her set
about the idea of like pushing her
culture forward she and Hassan had
talked about we want to be here and
pushing our culture forward and that I
think it's in something you just said
about how in families our community you
don't necessarily maybe have those
conversations do you foresee or do you
hope to see through even you know the
things that you're making that people
are seeing that you get to have that
evolution in among families and among
the community I hope our work can be a
catalyst for those conversations for
sure because
all that all that unsaid emotion is is
really deep-rooted and it could be the
cause of a lot of mental health stress
hmm and just a family drama that doesn't
need to be there and at the end of the
day we should be telling each other how
much we love each other yeah because the
parents you know they that's the least
you know that they should get yeah
that's yeah what's the significance for
you guys of premiering this in Toronto
at buffer fest well this is this is a
first because we actually haven't even
showed it on our channel yet right so
we're excited to to show it here it was
a HBO finalist APA visionaries finalist
and we've been kind of saving it so when
professors asked us back we said for
sure we got this one and we'd love to
share here and we also we shot almost
exactly a year ago so it's imaginary on
your anniversary yeah we're sure
yeah do you guys ever feel nervous about
presenting something that's important to
you out to the world always I think one
thing I won't we we definitely didn't
lean into our awkwardness and and how
not great we are in camera because it
and the more we are you know awkward and
not perfect the more real we are - yeah
you know so I'm always nervous whenever
it's a group or crowd because obviously
I want to put my best foot forward but
it's nice knowing that we do have a big
fan base here and they've been asking
for this story - that's also part of the
beauty of the democratization of media
with YouTube is like hashtag relatable
is that for a reason like it's not just
necessarily you know your family or how
you look but also you know people that
might feel awkward or people that don't
relate to the whole Hollywood structure
like this I can jump on board with this
there's no one mold of what you need to
be if you're on screen yeah I think
that's great and actually a lot of times
now we can root for the underdog because
they never had a platform so having been
on YouTube since basically the big bang
of them - at the beginning what's
something that you love about the
platform and something that you've seen
over the years that maybe you would love
to change or if all right I'll start
with the easy part
I love I love that it's a place for
people to learn and come together I like
that people can literally learn anything
on YouTube now yeah be self-taught be
their own star be their own studio and
make anything they want and I like
people I like that people can find
content that they can never find before
and be find other friends that are into
that and make friends off of that so the
community aspect is obviously the best
part in my opinion I think it's really
cool that like we're so connected with
our fans and our viewers that it seems
like they're just like you know we're
just one big family you know yeah being
like a huge fan of walking through
myself I never imagined I'd be you know
here sitting on this set I want food you
know being a part of it on this side
it's crazy so I think just interacting
with the fans and the viewers is just so
cool because you know I'm still a big
fan myself and yeah
seeing that that dynamic worked out
versus like the mainstream where there's
such a separation but I think it's
really cool to have events like you know
buffer fest yeah I mean all that to
really see how your work is affecting
people and investors on that know it's
great because it really elevates the the
content that people put a lot of working
to mm-hmm I think going back to my
version I said because YouTube has
everything it has a lot of a lot of
noise too I think
so maybe in the future I may be this
little self-serving but I hope that
there is maybe more of a focus or a
spotlight maybe on descriptive narrative
because it's it's slowly you know we're
not seeing that much of it anyway
especially as wall crew want food
productions and you know being here for
15 years we're looking to our left and
right and it's a being less and less
scripted narrative right it's hard to
make and it takes a lot of time so I
definitely understand but hopefully you
know our fans are great and they they're
always supportive of what we make but
it'd be really nice to see an emphasis
on that you know as long as there is
we're gonna keep making it yeah awesome
thanks guys yeah this is great Congrats
on the film on everything thanks Carlos
okay yeah yes
you